[Musique]
traverser une Highline en plein chantier
un scénario peut probable et pourtant
cette performance a bien vu le jour ce
weekend à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
[Musique]
et la star de l'événement c'est lui
Lucas Giovanni mourira à 33 ans
l'athlète professionnel de funambulisme
moderne détient plusieurs records dont
celui de la plus longue traversée en
2021 ce samedi il a offert un spectacle
vertigineux aux cinq continents en
traversant une corde de 110 mètres de
long accroché entre deux grues et
perchez à 40 mètres du sol le tout en
une vingtaine de minutes voilà les gens
sont là ils sont ébahis
de la performance parce que c'est
toujours assez
impressionnant de voir des gens marcher
dans l'air et de lever la tête aussi
parce qu'on a tendance à avec les
téléphones à toujours regarder très
proche de nous en direction du sol et
puis là on s'ouvre à quelque chose qui
est un peu plus aérien et ce n'est pas
tout en plus du spectacle l'événement
pensé par les promoteurs du Grand Paris
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et live a mis
à l'honneur l'association de
funambulisme Paris slack elle propose
des ateliers au sol pour initier des à
la slackline une expérience loin d'être
anodine pour de nombreux visiteurs
c'était très dur fallait être précis
il fallait avoir beaucoup d'équilibre je
pense que ça n'a absolument rien à voir
avec ce que Lucas a pu ressentir là-haut
mais bon c'est c'est amusant et c'est
assez grisant de de trouver aussi cette
équilibre sur en fait sur une ligne qui
n'est pas stable ces animations ont été
proposées au sein de l'écoquartier du
parc du lac actuellement en construction
le but faire découvrir ce nouvel espace
de la ville pensée pour répondre aux
enjeux actuels de développement durable
et de transition énergétique c'est
l'avantage c'est d'abord de proposer une
animation sympathique pour les habitants
et puis en plus de leur faire découvrir
leur quartier parce qu'on voit que là
les les personnes se promènent dans le
dans le quartier découvre les différents
espaces parce que il est quand même
assez vaste il y a 10 hectares un
échoquartier dont la livraison est
prévue pour 2024